well Donald Trump's own special Master
is kind of telling him to cut the crap
this is not going particularly well for
the failed former president so far and
it's super interesting because this is
exactly what Donald Trump wanted so let
me reset the story so we all get on the
same page one of the things really the
main thing that Donald Trump and his
lawyers did to try to slow down this
investigation by the FBI that happened
subsequent to the search warrant being
executed at Mar-A-Lago where all of
these documents were taken what Donald
Trump did is demand the appointment of a
special Master special Master would get
to take control of the documents seized
by the FBI and review them and say do
some of these have private medical
information are some of these privileged
in some way and slow down the FBI's
ability to use those documents in their
investigation Trump hand-picked a
special master and the special Master is
doing Donald Trump no favors and it's
actually a delight U.S this is from
talking points memo U.S District Judge
Raymond Deary for the eastern district
of New York injected some normalcy into
Trump's civil case against the justice
department Deary chastised attorneys for
Trump during the hearing for refusing to
produce any evidence that the record
seized by the FBI from Mar-A-Lago in
August had actually been Declassified
Jim trusts the a trump attorney told
Deary he wanted to examine the records
taken by the government as he decided
whether to make that assertion and Deary
said you can't have your cake and eat it
too Deary exhibited skepticism of the
Trump team's classification arguments
elsewhere in the hearing he kept asking
Trump's team versions of the same
question if I'm going to verify the
classification what am I looking for
um this is really really interesting
here is a report from CNN about what
went down
to Repose a question
case that the doctor classified perhaps
by the markings and if Trump's teams
don't tell him that these documents were
Declassified he said he essentially
would as far as he could as he is
concerned he would go with the Prima
fascia case and that would be the end of
it right so really putting the issue to
Trump's lawyers he noted that the burden
was on them in this case for them to
decide if they were going to put forward
any position that any of these documents
had been Declassified and as we've been
talking that is something that the
former president has said publicly on
his social media feed but it is not an
argument that his attorneys have made
yet in this case this is the best and
I've talked to you about this before one
of the I did a clip must have been about
two weeks ago where I said are Trump's
lawyers going to try these arguments in
court and one of the arguments was about
the classification status of some of the
C's documents and Trump's alleged broad
blanket Abracadabra declassification and
one of the things we've learned is that
a lot of the things you say in the media
don't hold up in court we saw this after
the 2020 election in the 60 plus cases
that were brought to different courts in
this particular case
in social media and elsewhere the
argument has been made Trump
Declassified everything and what the
special Master is saying is if you hand
me a document and it says classified and
you don't assert and prove that Trump
Declassified it
that's it it's a classified document and
that's all there is to it and this is
not what the Trump team was hoping for
really funny as Trump's legal team is
showing up to court there's someone
holding a nuclear secret sign in the
background and people yelling indict
Trump and all sorts of other hilarious
things
in America
all right so a brief moment of
excitement there outside the courthouse
I've said it before try it in court try
it under oath and then they don't so
we're going to be following this very
closely but early on this entire special
Master thing not going particularly well
for Donald Trump the paired app is a
really great tool to develop happier
relationships and to spark meaningful
conversations using thoughtfully
designed questions and activity prompts
paired is designed to be a fun and
entertaining way to learn more about
yourself and your partner that's what it
is quite simply the app uses
research-backed games questions quizzes
to reinforce and grow your relationship
it's simple and it's an effective way to
inspire really deep discussions with
your significant other this is not
couples therapy parrot is like going to
the gym but for your relationship it's
like a daily exercise for your
relationship and all of the exercises
were developed by academic psychologists
and expert relationship therapists as
well the app's daily prompts like
describe your partner's job in four
words or questions about intimacy or
money these can help start some of those
difficult to have conversations and
really bolster your relationship I've
been trying it out with my girlfriend
and it's really interesting and it
generates some really interesting
insights you can try paired for free for
seven days at paired.com Pacman the link
is down below